welcome back today is day of the dead or
dia de los muertos it's a mexican
holiday that dates back several thousand
years
and it's now celebrated around the world
including right here in las vegas
hector mejia live this afternoon from
the local mexican consulate where an
event wrapped up just a few moments ago
hector
well every year dia de los muertos pays
tribute to loved ones who are no longer
on earth with us and the tradition took
a different tone this year with the
mexican consulate here dedicating a
memorial to
everyone who has died from covet 19.
the vibrant holiday originated in mexico
and is now celebrated globally
the council of mexico in las vegas
juliana scutia and las vegas city
councilwoman olivia diaz
unveiled an altar called altar de
muertos
families traditionally placed pictures
of loved ones burned candles and incense
and spread bright marigold flowers on
altars that span several levels
dave the dead replaces mourning with a
celebration of both
life and death during the dedication the
mexican consulate read the names of 29
mexican nationals who died in nevada
to covet 19. they were
hard working people family
people they came to this country to
contribute
with their work with their values
with their traditions the positivity
rates
have disproportionately impacted our
latinos
i think mostly because we do have
frontline jobs where we can't work from
home
we have to be in person and surrounded
by people and so obviously the exposure
is um
sometimes more than other jobs but
thankfully our mortality rate
has not been the same as the positivity
in terms of how kovitt has impacted
services here they're following kovitt
19 safety measures
the mexican consulate said they help
about a hundred people a day
they even expanded hours to keep up with
that demand and they're now open
8 a.m until 6 p.m on weekdays whereas
before
they were only open until 2 in the
afternoon reporting near the arts
district hector mejia
8 news now